So I hope everyone understands the main idea behind the hash
table now. Our goal is to map a keyword and a
number of buckets. Using our hash-string function to a particular bucket
and that bucket will contain all of the keywords that map to
that location. So now what we're going to do is try to
actually write the code to do this. We're going to start from
our index that we wrote for the previous unit, but try
to figure out how to implement that with a hash table instead.
So the first question is, how is this going to change our data structure? So
this was what we had before, if you remember we had our index was a list
of keywords, we had a list of entries, and each entry was a pair,
which was a keyword. And the second element of the pair was the list of
the URLs where that word appears, and we would have each word in the index
as its own entry with its own list of URLs. So
this was the data structure that we used last class. Now
we want to change things to implement a hash table. So,
I want you to think about what data structure we'll use
and we'll make that a quiz to decide a good data
structure to use to implement the hash table. So the question
is which of these data structures would make most sense to
implement the hash table index? The first choice is a list.
Where the elements in the list are. A list where the
first element is a word and the second element is a
list of URLs where that word appears. The second choice is
a list where each element in a list is the list itself
where the first element is a word and the second element
is a list of lists where each element in that list
is a list of URLs. So, the third choice is a
list. Where each element is a list. Where the element lists themselves
contain lists. Where the element lists of the element
list are a list of the word, all by
a list of all the URLs for that word.
So, we have three nested lists for choice three.
For choice four, we have a list where each
element in the list is a list. Where within
the element list, there is another list, which is
a list of words, followed by a list of URLs.
And for the final choice, we also have three nest of lists, where each element
is a list, where the elements of that list are a list, that are word
followed by a list. Where each element in that list is a list of urls.
So which one of these would be the best structure to implement a hash table?